bieber dans la tourmente après des
révélations sur les méthodes du géant
américain pour s'imposer sur le marché
du vtc à travers le monde un rendez vous
secret est alors organisée le matin même
dans le bureau du ministre avec tout
l'état major du beurre dont son pdg de
l'époque travis canonique à la sortie
dans un email son lobbyiste est
euphorique en un mot spectaculaire du
jamais vu meeting méga top avec emmanuel
macron ce matin la france nous aime un
prénom il ya une collusion d'intérêts le
fait qu'un ministre de l'économie contre
son gouvernement participe à installer
une précarisation du travail en fait
c'est grave ce qui s'est passé ça paraît
bizarre que dans un gouvernement
un seul homme décide à la place de tous
et à l'insu de leur plein gré comme
disait quelqu'un il était manifestement
le seul en tout cas prohibe rc j'ose
dire heureusement que nos ministres de
l'économie et de l'industrie peuvent
continuer à recevoir des entreprises
faire en sorte que ces entreprises
s'implantent en france qu'elles créent
de l'emploi en france qu'elle crée un
service que les français d'ailleurs
plébiscite très très largement ça met la
lumière sur ce qu'est emmanuel macron ou
sur ce qu'il a été en tous les cas
lorsqu'il était ministre de l'économie
et des finances un lobbyiste au service
d'intérêts privés étrangers emmanuel
macron a été l'allié d'une entreprise
qui fait du contournement fiscal
c'est-à-dire qu'ils domicile qui
domicilié à ses activités aux pays-bas
notamment pour payer moins d'impôts en
france qui déclarait 50 millions par
exemple de chiffre d'affaires en 2010
est alors que la réalité d'ailleurs
c'était bfm je crois qui avait sorti un
article sur sa était autour de 200
millions d'euros est ce qu un ministre
de l'économie a droit d'être convaincu
par les arguments qui lui sont apportés
bien évidemment donc mal géré j'ai
regardé qu'est-ce-qui des caisses qui
était illégal qu'est le quel était le
problème je n'ai rien trouvé on peut
considérer que ça c'est quand même grave
quand une entreprise et perquisitionnés
par des agents de bercy et que
l'entreprise elle même averti le
ministre en lui disant est-ce que vous
pouvez nous conseillez qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire il ya quand même un problème
et un dysfonctionnement malgré le en
même temps permanent le parcours des
manuels macro à une cohérence un fil
rouge servir des intérêts privés souvent
étrangers
avant les intérêts nationaux saint
idéologues de la dérégulation un
idéologue de la mondialisation qui
effectivement à chaque fois qu'il l'a pu
a fait avancer cette dérégulation a fait
avancer cette politique qui limite
effectivement les règles de droit pour
permettre à chacun de faire ce qu'il
veut comme il veut et nous mêmes nous
saisirons très rapidement dans la
semaine et ce sera évidemment transmis à
la presse des questions écrites très
précises à bercy qui vont renforcer l'
enquête qui est faite par les
journalistes actuellement son surnom de
président des ultras riches n'est pas
usurpée et puis que
il ya besoin de plus de transparence
dans les prises de décisions au plus
haut niveau de l'état
mieux pour tout le monde sont commission
enquête de l'assemblée nationale qui
pourra faire la lumière en cinq ans de
pouvoir
macron et de sa majorité la fortune des
500 plus riche de france est passée de
570 milliards à 1000 milliards c'est
quasiment doublé la motion de censure de
la nuque contre le gouvernement
d'elisabeth bornes mises au vote
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée pourtant elle
n'a que très peu d'espoir d'être adopté
elle va être votée par la france
insoumise et hannut baisse qui est
contrôlé en faites par la france un
soumises elles ne seul n'aboutira pas et
elle sera simplement le signe d'une
sorte d'opposition radicale encore une
preuve de l'effet du réchauffement
climatique
l'effondrement d'un glacier vous voyez
qui a provoqué une vague une avalanche
au kirghizistan je vois une vertu à
cette motion de censure c'est qu'elle va
définitivement démontré que will
président de la république a été réélue
et que non jean luc mélenchon n'a pas
gagné la présidentielle que non jean luc
mélenchon n'a pas gagné les législatives
et que will hahn ubs est clairement une
minorité à l'assemblée nationale
effondrement d'un glacier donc kirghize
oh là là attention ça arrive à bien très
bien